And to that right I would like to address today
to the popular party to ask for sanity and restraint,
sanity and restraint
and to tell them
that what they should do
is to accept the result of the ballot boxes,
the legitimacy of the government that we will soon form
in Spain.
Who have the necessary courage
to say no to the embrace of the bear of the ultra-right wing
and to abandon the reactionary machinery by which today
advance into the abyss.
Because with your vote,
Spanish and Spanish citizens
we were told last July 23rd
that Spain can only be governed
if your country's political pluralism is recognized
and also its territorial diversity.
The popular party
only understood
and can only agree with 1 political force,
which is the ultra-right wing of Vox,
with no one else